قانون التقاعد الجديد في فرنسا يبدو انه
لن يخرج الى النور وان خرج ستكون ضريبته
كبيره مع المواجهه والاحتجاجات الواسعه
والرفض الواسع من الموظفين الذين عبروا عن
ذلك باضراب ثان اليوم شارك فيه نحو ثلاثه
ملايين بعموم فرنسا هذا بحسب نقبات اما
بحسب وزاره الداخليه الفرنسيه فالعديد
يبلغ نحو مليون
و750,000 وشهد عده قطاعات في فرنسا كالنقل
العمومي والمدارس وانتاج الكهرباء والنقل
والمصافي النفطيه ووسائل اعلام حكوميه
اليوم شللا بعد اقرار يوم الثامن ثامن من
التعب الشعبيه ضد مشروع قرار حكوميه لدافع
سن التقاعد من الى اربعه 64 عاما رمضان عن
اثنين و 60 عاما وتم تشغيل واحد فقط من كل
ثلاثه قطارات في العاليه السرعه اليوم
الثلاثاء وعدد اقل من القطارات المحليه
والاقليم مع تعطيل مترو باريس بشده وهنا
قالت نقابه المعلمين في المدارس
الابتدائيه في فرنسا ان نصف المعلمين
اضربوا عن العمل وبالمثل يضرب ايضا موظفون
وصافي النفطيه والعاملين في قطاعات اخرى
من بينها طبعا محطات البث الحكوميه التي
بثت الموسيقى بدلا من البرامج الاخباريه
وانخفضت امدادات الطاقه الفرنسيه اربعه
فاصله 4% فهم ضمن العاملون في المفاعلات
النوويه ومحطات الطاقه الحراريه الى
الاضراب ايضا وفقا لبيانات همم السلطه
[موسيقى]